edward glaeser is the 11th arrow siren
and lecturer the siren and lecture
series bring speakers to the school who
have an important impact on architecture
but who are not necessarily themselves
architects of course I just learned that
mr. glazier is the son of an architect I
don't know where that puts them in the
category of siren and lecturers I did
actually know his father vary quite a
bit the first sound of lecturer was a
Anthony a Williams the mayor of
Washington DC then the mayor of
Washington DC another Saturday lecturer
was Thomas Krenz then the director of
the Guggenheim Museum and the 10th siren
and lecturer was the journalist and
author Tom Vanderbilt they were just
wonderful seats down here let's come on
down
i think i'm going to rope off the back
seats every razor is the Fred and
Eleanor glimp professor of economics at
Harvard University where he thought
since 1992 a graduate of Princeton and
the university of chicago from which he
received his PhD in economics professor
Glaser has been widely published in a
number of academic and research journals
such as the Journal of urban economics
Daedalus and the american economic
review he is a contributor to Bloomberg
News and his writing has appeared
regularly in the Wall Street Journal and
The New York Times exploring topics such
as housing markets crime segregation
transportation networks and public
spending professor glazers authors
several books including agglomeration
economics published by the University of
Chicago in 2010 exploring and and
general equilibrium and I MIT the same
year and recently he published triumph
of the city how our greatest invention
makes us richer smarter greener
healthier and happier and published by
penguin press and the cover is on the
screen it is in triumph of the city that
dr. Glazer presents not only an
enthusiastic argument for the innovation
and and opportunities for economic and
cultural aggregation that come out of
cities can be born in the cities but
also takes critical aim at public
policies designed to reinforce reinforce
and foster suburbanization please join
me in welcoming edward glaeser to our
schools podium as he delivers this terms
arrow siren and lecture building a city
of choices
I'm really terribly honored to be here
as was just said my father was an
architectural historian and I think who
were just based on preferences and
reverence for architecture I would
certainly rather be among you than to be
an economist unfortunately I was born as
you will soon observe with an utter lack
of any aesthetic discernment whatsoever
so so your path is bar to me and I had
to make do with I had to make do with
economics I want to start illustrating
my my lack of aesthetic sense with a
picture only economists would call this
a picture of the United States and what
I've done in this picture is to split
America's counties into tents each of
those doctors is about 300 counties and
I've arranged them by density levels by
how many people per square mile there
are in each one of these counties from
the least dense counties to the most
dense counties the bottom line shows the
relationship between per capita income
and density across America's counties
and as you can see it's a strictly
increasing line that the densest tenth
of America's counties have income levels
that are on average more than fifty
percent higher no it didn't work oh
thank you well let's see if we can get
the technology no I've got a pointer i
need a clicker okay all right all right
all right but then I can't walk around
it's my whole my whole shtick is off the
okay the the most dense tenth of
America's counties are on average fifty
percent oh no I know how to fix this
it's this thing came out that's I think
that should do it yes wonderful okay got
it all right the most dense tenth of
America's counties are on average fifty
percent earn fifty percent more per
capita than the least dense fifth of
America's counties this is a general
phenomena that's been documented in
almost every society known to known to
us that as people conglomerate together
come together in cities and cities are
at their heart the absence of physical
space between people they are density
their proximity their closeness and as
density increases productivity
innovation
earnings increase as well the three
largest metropolitan areas in the United
States produce eighteen percent of
america's gross domestic product well
including only thirteen percent of
america's population and if the rest of
america saw its per capita output rise
to the level seen in the New York
metropolitan area our national incomes
would go up by over forty percent the
top line is perhaps is somewhat more
curious fact that shows the relationship
between population growth between 2000
and 2010 and initial density levels and
what you can see is that as density
increases population growth does as well
at least until you get to the densest
tenth of counties whereas in the start
of the 19th century we left our dense
enclaves on the Atlantic Ocean to
populate the great open spaces the
American hinterland as we face the 21st
century we're increasingly moving back
moving towards the old of the old city
is moving towards new cities that are
being formed moving towards density
moving towards agglomeration this
connection shouldn't surprise us what
you're looking at here is the
relationship between initial income and
growth over the past ten years I split
the counties in this case in two fifths
and as you can see the wealthiest fifth
of counties as of the year 2000
experienced average growth rate of about
fifteen percent whereas the least
wealthy fifth of America's counties lost
population there was a strong tendency
of people to follow the money which
perhaps isn't particularly surprising
but this tendency of people to follow
the money explains this somewhat odd
fact and you have split counties by
proximity to a major port and what you
can see here is that the places that are
closest to ports grew much more quickly
than the places that are farther away
from ports this of course doesn't mean
that we're all becoming stevedores for
goodness sakes it's not as if
containerisation will rule backwards and
the wharves of New Haven have come alive
again as everyone's working on it but
it's that those ports are the nuclei of
the great metropolitan areas that are
the real economic heartland of the
United States now the success of
America's cities which is seen in their
safety and their social innovation in
their economic productivity in their
high housing prices in their high levels
of income is dwarfed by the urban
transformation that is going on through
the world as
whole right we've just about five years
ago across that somewhat remarkable
halfway point where more than fifty
percent of humanity now lives in cities
that it's hard not to see that
fundamentally as a hopeful sign because
if you compare those countries that are
more than fifty percent urbanized to
those countries that are less than fifty
percent urbanized the more urbanized
countries have incomes that are on
average five times higher and infant
mortality levels that are less than a
third of those countries that are that
are less than fifty percent urbanized
it's not that we necessarily should ever
try and force people off of off of rural
areas into cities and indeed you know I
think in fact having a plethora of
choices both within and across cities is
a wonderful thing this is very much the
Economist perspective on this but it's
hard not to see giving how incredibly
tight the link has been between
urbanization and prosperity that cities
are part of a process where humankind
moves out of a world that was you know
dreadful to a world where there is more
more promise and lest you get to
misty-eyed about you know sure you know
the rural pass was poor but boy it was
happy right everyone was living on these
farms and having a great time of it well
clearly if you think that you haven't
been to rural India lately or many of
the rural areas of the the poor
countries in the world this is the
relationship between self-reported
happiness and the share of the
population that's urban across countries
and what you can see is that people tend
to say that they're happier when they're
living in more urbanized countries it is
not true of course that within the
United States that people who live in
urban areas typically say that they're
happier than people who live in
non-urban areas what self-respecting New
Yorker is going to admit that they're
happy anyway but it is true in fact when
you compare urban and rural areas in the
developing world there's a huge
self-reported happiness gap where people
who live in cities typically say that
their well-being is higher now this fact
runs against a long-standing hostility
to cities both in this country and
elsewhere think about the Jeffersonian
tradition one that has I think very
unfortunate consequences for our modern
policy environment where we often act as
if living behind a white picket fence in
the suburb is the only way to be a real
American and the same thing is true in
the developing world where there exists
a tremendous
see to idealize the rural past Gandhi
famously said the growth of the nation
depends not on cities but on its
villages right he had an image of a
world in which everyone would spin their
own cloth and yet with all due respect
to the great man he was wrong right the
growth of India does not depend on its
on its agriculture the growth of Africa
certainly does not depend on soil which
is very far from being the world's
leader in terms of providing a cultural
products it depends upon cities
providing a transformation cities is the
gateways across cultures and
civilizations that enable places like
Bangalore to be ways in which indeed to
be transformational areas that can
enable India to move into the 21st
century this is an image of the mindtree
campus in Bangalore and I am NOT I have
absolutely no opinion on its
architectural merits whatsoever so so
I'm not trying to put it up for that but
it's an amazing place because within
this building within this box here is
just a hive of connected humanity that
the software engineers get together
every every day and they eat lunch on
the roof and the place is just crowded
and jamming with people exchanging ideas
and of course it's not just Indian
software engineers and exchanging ideas
with other Indian software engineers
it's a place in which people from
throughout the world be it you know
other other software people from Silicon
Valley or be it investors from Singapore
being even the occasional socially
awkward Harvard professor comes by and
and you know tries to connect with this
mindtree software consulting consulting
thing and to try and be part of that now
the other image is the street life in
Bangalore outside of man of mine tree
and it's a messy street life it's a
street life that actually you know I
find I find deeply exciting but it also
reminds us of how challenging urban
areas are and I will you know I will
come back to this over and over again
but it's important that as I'm giving a
very Pro urban talk to remember that
there are downsides of density and that
cities require management and that while
the cities of India offer tremendous
promise they offer also often tremendous
challenges one way to think about this
is an abundance of land hides many sins
on the part of government right you
actually don't need to be extremely
competent to get you know rural Montana
to be basically functional but once you
cram people together it requires a huge
amount of government investment right
the cities and towns of America we're
spending as much on water
start of the 20th century's the federal
government was spending on everything
except for the post office in the army
there's a reason why people in New York
City like government more than people in
Montana do they need it more all right
and Indian fact needs to make
investments that will make their cities
livable and in order to have them play
out the promise that they offer now
bangalore and the general trend towards
urbanization leads to what i think which
i think is the central paradox of my
talk and indeed i think it's a central
paradox of our age which is that we live
in an age in which it is effortless to
telecommute across the planet in which
we can all occupy whatever Sylvan spot
appeals to I by Ophelia and just just
dial it in right just connect
electronically from our own little you
know electronic cottage I think it was
the phrase that one of the cyber Sears
once used and just connect without ever
having to be next to each other now this
was a view that was espoused 30 years
ago with complete conference that cities
were going to be killed by by new
communications technologies and yet that
really does not seem to be what happened
at all that in so many ways whether it's
in Bangalore in Boston or in London or
in Beijing right the the cities of the
world are thriving and are growing at
breakneck pace in the developing world
and our was urgent in the in the
developed world and that's really a
puzzle why didn't electronic
communications kill cities and it's an
important thing for us to understand
this because it tells us whether or not
we're just in a temporary world in which
cities have come back briefly or whether
or not we think actually the long-run
trend is far from dispersing humanity
will actually continue to bring us
together now this relatively rosy view
of cities is so different than the new
york city of my youth right these are
two iconic images from the 1970s in New
York when the city really did seem to
lose its way it was a city that was
marked by fiscal distress it was marked
by enormous crime problems and it was
marked above all by incredible
industrial decline the largest economic
cluster in the United States the largest
industrial cluster in the United States
in the 1950s was not automobile
production in Detroit right it was
garment production in new york city and
the garment industry was hammered far
more than automobiles were by the first
wave of globalization in the 1960s 1970s
New York was shedding hundreds of
thousands of jobs that
Nanak decline is the backdrop for the
fiscal crisis of the 1970s of course a
little bit of government mismanagement
didn't hurt for creating that crisis but
it left New York in a position where it
was desperately begging the federal
government to bail it out and and Ford
didn't literally tell the city to drop
dead but most people think he actually
did mean it and indeed it looked like
not just President Ford but history
itself was telling New York City and
Boston and Buffalo and San Francisco to
drop dead in the 1970s it really looked
as if their whole reason for being had
evaporated during this time period that
they would dinosaurs headed for the
trash heap of history indeed this image
of President Carter wandering through
the wasteland that the South Bronx had
become offered one quite plausible
vision of what was going to happen to
cities they were going to hollow out and
become this sort of quasi agricultural
waste land because in fact the whole
economic rationale of cities had
vanished I mean it wasn't just an issue
of the city seeming unmanageable it was
questioning why in the world were
relocating in these very expensive old
things now to understand why things look
so bleak then and why they don't look
like now I think it's important to go
even further back to understand why
America's cities came about to begin
with on some very basic mechanistic
level America's cities the older cities
grew up to solve a transportation
problem here we were at the start of the
19th century on the edge of a vast
enormously wealthy nation right filled
with rich soil and mineral wealth and
yet it was virtually inaccessible it
cost as much in 1816 to move goods 30
miles over land as it did to ship them
across the Atlantic Ocean right
enormously expensive to get anywhere
away from the Atlantic seaboard and so
he perched on that seaboard clinging to
our oceanic lifeline cities were you
know there and they were typically on
the place where the river meets the sea
but only gradually over the 19th century
as we built this network first the great
canals hearing Illinois in Michigan and
then the railroads that supplemented the
canals that enabled the wealth of the
hinterland to make its way to the market
to the east and europe and cities grew
up on pinch points
on crucial nodes of those that
transportation network like Buffalo of
course the western terminus of the Erie
Canal where Joseph darts elevators of
great 19th century innovation lifted the
grain coming off the connect the boats
on the Great Lakes onto the ultimately
onto the canal boats on Chicago of
course the linchpin of a great watery
ark that went all the way from New York
to New Orleans and these places grew up
as part of a way of handling this
transportation problem of course
industries then follow the ports right
industries then became grew up around
these natural places that had a
transportation cost advantage the three
dominant industries in New York in the
19th century were sugar refining
printing and publishing and the garment
trade all three of these industries were
children of the port as indeed New
York's dominant industry today finance
was as well right sugar refining was
natural there because New York did so
much trade with the Caribbean and of
course you couldn't refined sugar in the
Caribbean during the early 19th century
and ship it North because refined sugar
crystals would coalesce during a long
hot sea voyage north you needed to
refine them close to the point of
production but hopefully in a central
location where you could take advantage
of scale economies because sugar
refineries were expensive products and
indeed great family fortunes like that
that eventually put franklin delano
roosevelt in the White House were formed
off sugar refining in New York by people
like Isaac Roosevelt right who was not
contrary to what mad men may tell you
and indeed madman does mention Isaac
Roosevelt and describes him farming I've
no I did not know that I suppose about
did any farming but I sure do know he
did a lot of sugar refining which is a
perfectly good urban occupation and in
fact he is involvement with politics
that his Isaac Roosevelt's not Franklin
specifically reflected his unhappiness
with British mercantilist policies
during the during the mid and late 18th
century of course the garment trade as
well huge amounts of fabric coming in
and out of out of New York because the
trade both with England and wig with a
Caribbean right the first regularly
scheduled packet service in New York was
put together by Jeremiah Thompson right
whose role in shipping vast amounts of
fabric was because he came out of an
English in English English ship will
making will making family and of course
my favorite story of this is why
printing publishing is so became so
dominant to New York City the big money
in 19th century printing and publishing
was of course in pirated
English novels right no you know Asian
property rights thief had anything on
our boys in the 1820s and indeed the
thing is with a pirated novel right
you've really got a published first
you're not going to make any money off
the eighth pirated edition of girl with
the dragon tattoo right you really have
to have the first one to hit the market
and if you've got the first one hit the
market then it's really crucial to be in
the central port because in fact the
Harper brothers could get Peveril the
peak could get this latest sir walter
scott novel before you know days before
it even showed up in the in the hands
that they're philadelphia competitors
carry and lee and could flood the market
with this thing before Karen Lee could
could bring it out right and this played
a crucial role in giving the Harper
brothers their dominance in American
publishing during the early 19th century
of course Chicago's great industry by
value added although not by employment
the garment trade was dominant chicago
by employment as well but the great
industry by value added was the
stockyards right an industry that very
much grew up around the transportation
system the the stockyards were basically
part of an age-old problem in america
which is how the heck do you get corn to
market so america has this great soil
for growing corn we still do although we
do more magical hybrid forming forms
than we ever did in the past but it's we
still incredibly rich corn corn corn
yields and and we did then as well
particularly in the soil near chicago
which then replaced the older corn hub
Cincinnati which had taken advantage of
this the rich soil of the Ohio River
Valley originally of course we shipped
corn in whiskey form alright whiskey
being a portable and often quite tasty
means of transporting corn corn products
in that of course we moved to salted
pork and it needs Cincinnati was
America's pork opolis right because in
fact salted the pork was a way to make
it durable Chicago grew first in terms
of shipping pork and then when this
clever guy armor figured out that you
could have these refrigerated rail cars
by putting the ice on top of the beef
instead of below it so would drip down
that was apparently the great innovation
they managed to creep put the stockyards
there as well right a great industry
very naturally in Chicago a central
location where you could transform the
the live cattle into dressed beef and
move it on the rails East now even when
cities form for uh turley prosaic
reasons miracles happen when smart
people connect with each other and so it
was in Chicago in the 1880s and this is
of course for me by far the most
perilous slide for me to get through
because it's the only one that really
has anything to do with architecture and
as such as the area which I'm far most
like more likely to play a to make a
major error but this of course is is
jenny's home insurance building called
by some although of course not by all
the first skyscraper now Jenny's
building it of course this is actually
the 1990s the 1890s version which has
the extra I think for extra stories
that's that but there's of course a
lively architectural history debate
about whether or not this narrative of
Jenny as the as the inventor of the
skyscraper is actually accurate meaning
of course the skyscraper having some
form of steel or cast iron skeleton and
being a relatively tall building um
there of course this debate has been
going on since the 1880s when Buffington
had his patent that he fought for so
assiduously um I think the main the main
hub of the debate right now of course is
that the only the two front walls of
this building at least in the Articles
that I've read someone may know better
only the two front walls here are have a
steel skeleton right the back to party
walls have a traditional masonry masonry
structure and indeed there appears to be
a lively architectural debate history
debate about whether or not Jenny
deserves this title or whether or not
should go to holla Varden roach or
whether or not should go to Sullivan or
whether or not should go to burnham but
the reason why I bring this up and the
reason why I love this story is it makes
I think a central point about human
creativity and about cities which is
that the skyscraper like pretty much
anything else that we as human beings
have ever done was not a solo affair
right it was a social creation it was a
result of smart architects who worked
with each other right all of these guys
right holla board Roche Sullivan and
burnham all were at one point time
apprentices in Jenny's office right they
all clearly borrowed ideas from one
another they all clearly built on each
other's ideas they were part of a chain
of creativity
that created the modern skyscraper right
this vision which an ran gave us of you
know Louis Sullivan working alone contra
to everything right it could not be
farther from the truth right we get
smart by being around other smart people
this is how we grow this is what we are
are you know born to do and this is how
it was in the 1880s as well when a you
know the great fire and the growth of
Chicago created this influx of genius
all of which became much greater because
it worked together a similar thing
happened in Detroit in the 1890s all
right the skyscrapers in one sense is
the transformation of a city using one
form of transportation technology right
because it's not just a voice about the
technology building up it's also about
the elevator right without which the
modern skyscraper is utterly
unimaginable which is fundamentally a
transportation revolution but there's
another transportation revolution of
course that pulled us out rather than up
that went on in Detroit in the 1890s
Detroit of course classic part of that
transportation network de tois the
Straits and it was natural that Detroit
would have industries would have firms
like Detroit dry dock a cutting-edge
industrial firm that worked on producing
ship's repairing them engines that ply
the inland waterways of America and it
was a training ground for young people
like this character Henry Ford who came
off the farm and got his start working
on engines for Detroit dry dock cities
then as now our forges of human capital
places that we come to learn from people
around us Ford then moved on to working
with Edison and then got involved in
this great race of American tinkerers in
the 1890s to come up with the affordable
car of course Germans in their cities
had figured out the basic technology of
making automobiles but they hadn't
figured out how to make them cheaply and
that was our great innovation but Ford
no more than you know no more than Louis
Sullivan was an Ayn Rand hero right Ford
was one of a cluster of automotive
geniuses in Chicago according to the
first person actually build a car in
Detroit's I am in Detroit there the
first person to build a car in Detroit
was Charles Kirby and according to
legend Henry Ford followed Charles Kirby
on a bicycle as he drove his car up and
down the streets of Detroit desperately
trying to figure out how Kirby's car
work
now I suspect this story is false but I
so loved the image of Ford pedaling
furiously trying to learn from Kirby's
innovation that I can't give it up but
and of course Ford was not the only
innovator in Detroit right i mean they
were the dodge brothers the fisher
brothers David Dunbar Buick Billy Durant
nearby flint ransom e olds right every
one of whom knew each other worked with
each other supplying each other with
parts with financing and most of all
with ideas right and together they did
this amazing thing they figured out how
to make mass-produced cars an invention
with incredible ramifications for the
world and in many ways a very benevolent
innovation of course in many ways and
not so benevolent innovation the problem
of course from the city level is the
form that Ford's innovation took because
the way that he figured out how to make
cheap cars was to do it on a vast scale
I'd in plants like the Rouge right vast
vertically integrated walled off from
the outside world employing tens of
thousands of less well educated
Americans giving them good jobs on one
sense this was a fantastic thing in the
short run for Detroit in some in by some
measures Detroit was the most productive
place in the planet in 1950 because of
this idea right on the other hand this
was a terrible model for long-run
reinvention of the city successful
cities at the start of the 19th century
in the late 18th century like Birmingham
in the age of both of Matthew Boulton
and James Watt or like new york and the
age of Alexander Hamilton were marked by
smart people small firms and connections
to the outside world the same thing is
true of successful cities today how far
from that is the Rouge right vast firm
walled off from the outside world
employing lots of less educated workers
this model right may be good in the
short run but ultimately you don't need
to put this back to in the city and when
conditions change when transportation
technologies change it makes just as
much sense to move the place somewhere
else where it's cheaper it follows the
logic of cost minimization and that
logic tends to be very painful for
cities and so as transportation costs
declined and what you're looking at is
the real cost of moving a ton a mile by
rail during the 20th century which
not that ninety percent over the 20th
century so that while in 1900 or 19 20
or even 1930 it made sense to locate a
factory near the old rail network near
the Great Lengths right by 1970 those
transportation cost advantages had
become obsolete and you might as well
move it to a right to work state you
might as well move it to a suburb you
might as well move it to across the
Pacific Ocean to wherever labor is
cheapest wherever you can save a few
dollars and so that's exactly what
happened to manufacturing in the United
States right it moved from the old Rust
Belt cities it departed and it seems
very unlikely that it will ever come
back again because it's fundamentally
not what cities do that aren't that
that's good these changes hit all of
America's older colder cities in some
sense one way to think about is the
decline in transportation costs meant
that we no longer had to locate in
places where you know firms had a
productive advantage like access to
Pittsburgh's coal mines or or access to
the waterways we could locate in places
where people wanted to live this is a
index that i put together based
essentially on people's the price that
people were willing to pay for houses in
the area in 1980 controlling for income
so it says how much extra two people
seem to be willing to pay for these
areas which is one reflection of how you
know how high the amenities are and as
you can see it's very strongly
predictive people have moved to areas
that have consumer amenities that make
things attractive for people to live
rather than places that have innate
productive advantages like coal mines
now of course the consumer amenity that
people appear to care about most is
January temperature okay because what
you're looking at here is the ranking of
America's counties into fifth based on
January temperature and the subsequent
population growth between 2000-2010 and
I know of no variable over the course of
the 20th century was better predicts
metropolitan area growth than January
temperature now that's not just about
the moving to consumer-related cities
it's also about a number of different
factors which go together the
elimination of the diseases which stop
the the old the cities of the old sound
the rise of the air conditioner the
connection of the south was relatively
pro-business policies the work of tom
holmes at the university of minnesota
shows a tremendous divide right on the
board of right-to-work states where
manufacturing grew in the anti-union
states and declined in the pro-union
states and of course in recent decades
it's very associated with relatively
Pro building policies but it's just a
lot easier to lay down tens of thousands
of units in Houston than it is in Boston
all of these things come together but
you know there's something to be said
for warm January's as well or at least
the majority of Americans think so and
of course along with the move to Sun was
the move to sprawl we've always built
our cities in ways that reflect the
dominant transportation technology in
the era in which we built our older
cities have these wonderful you know
pedestrian walkways with narrow streets
and short blocks that are connected with
the way that we just walk around and
then me as we added wheels to the mix we
put lay down grids and created our
streets that are straight and then we
sprawled further in the age of the
elevated rail car in the age of the
streetcar suburb as sam bass warner road
and of course in the twentieth century
we rebuilt our cities around the car
right it's not surprising that we did so
it's not surprising that was huge demand
for this the average commute by car in
this country is 24 minutes the average
commute by public transit is 48 minutes
right it's not surprising that Americans
want this and it's not surprising that
developers and created structures built
around this and on some basic level all
right as an economist and this is again
the sort of perspective of the economist
who values choice I think that it's good
that people have choices I indeed also
once I started acquiring small kids also
moved to a suburb as much as I dream of
some time 15 years from now when my last
chilled my last child is out of high
school and I can move to a studio
apartment in a city but the problem of
course is that it's not as if cities and
suburbs are competing on a level playing
field all right and the problem is not
with the fact that some people choose
suburbs it's fine that people choose
summers the problem is that in fact we
have stacked the deck and we stacked the
deck with a series of policies like the
home mortgage interest deduction which
creates a strong incentive to leave
urban apartments and move to suburban
homes it also creates an incentive to
borrow as much as possible to bet on the
vicissitudes of the housing market and
to build larger homes we also stack the
deck with the highway system the work of
Nathaniel bounce no shows that each new
highway that cut into a metropolitan
area in the post-war period reduced the
central city's population by about
eighteen percent relative of the
metropolitan area as a whole and it is
utterly amazing to me that President
Obama who is in many ways the most urban
president we've had since Theodore
Roosevelt right has become such a huge
champion of highway spending because in
fact when you
here infrastructure stimulus you should
think highways in Montana because in
fact that's where those dollars go right
they go for the transportation they
follow the traditional highway trust
fund formula right and that's that's
what has happened and it's not you know
it's not as if there's you know all
highways are wrong especially if they're
paid for by the users and especially
people pay for the environmental cost of
their action but we should be wary about
using general tax revenues to subsidize
people to drive the removed to sun and
sprawl hit all of america's olders
colder cities these were the ten largest
cities in America in 1950 and eight out
of them lost twenty percent of the
population or more over the next 50
years three out of them lost forty-eight
percent of their population or more over
the next 50 years in Detroit lost
another twenty five percent of the
population since 2000 over the last
decade just a complete hollowing out of
these cities accompanied of course by
the social distress that so often can
come along with economic decline this is
an image I hope since I haven't looked
back at it it's an image of the Detroit
riot in 1967 sort of sense that
civilization which was in some sense
created by cities had left it that that
chaos was was in control and the federal
government again didn't make things
better they followed us something of a
Potemkin village strategy of thinking
the real heart of the city was it
structures an infrastructure and not the
people now that doesn't mean that I
don't believe that structures an
infrastructure plane absolutely vital
role in making cities work of course
they do of course I structures a crucial
to it but the hallmark of declining
cities is that they have an abundance of
buildings and an abundance of
infrastructure relative to the number of
people relative to the level of demand
right more than ninety percent of the
homes in central city Detroit are
currently priced below the physical cost
of construction even assuming Texas
passive construction even assuming
eighty bucks a square foot okay it can't
possibly make sense to use policies to
subsidize more home construction in
these areas it didn't make sense to
subsidize the building of new homes
there in the 50s and 60s when this is
exactly what urban renewal policies did
and it certainly never sent made sense
in a city in which you know there are
less than half the people there than the
word the city is its height which you
can get
easily because the roads aren't
typically crowded it never made sense to
build a monorail to glide over
essentially empty streets in Detroit and
yet this is what the federal government
did starting into the federal highway 28
Act of 1973 it was there to you know
invest in these systems based on a will
of the wisp story right that despite the
fact that there was no obvious demand
for this thing that Samara that would be
transformational it would move cities
now I believe in infrastructure but it's
so easy to tell ourselves myths stories
about how infrastructure can be
transformational that without hard data
that actually goes through the
cost-benefit analysis we so often make
mistakes like that famous Simpsons
episode where the music man sold a
monorail to their to their town I think
that's a fairly realistic episode the
the sad truth of Matt rail transit this
is from the work of Nathaniel bounce no
Matthew con is that this in the shows
the change in the share of the
population using public transit
associated with a new rail line a new a
new subway line after the 1973 federal
highway tact and even if you change what
this thing means is even if you started
six kilometers away from a subway stop
and had all of that eradicated right
that changed the share of the population
using public transit by exactly three
percentage points right that's how
little it moved it the ability to get
Americans out of their cars into subway
lines is very very limited and that for
that reason you need to be very careful
about throwing hundreds of millions of
dollars at this at this infrastructure
you do however you know want to be quite
aggressive at making sure that drivers
pay for the social cost of their actions
right so you do want to modding very
hard about whether it's congestion
prices or the appropriate carbon taxes
this is an image of Detroit dry dock
today which is still in many senses and
again I shouldn't get out of my late but
i still find myself falling totally in
love with this building i mean it's an
amazing example of cutting-edge
industrial architecture during its time
but of course it also is is a tragic
right it also is a symbol of what was
once great now is gone now of course the
story doesn't end there detroit night
still has some chance of coming back and
I'm still rooting for the city but some
cities like New York like Boston like
San Francisco like Seattle were able to
come back while others didn't
right there are two ways at
understanding why some got back and some
didn't one is a way through stories and
the other way is through statistics now
the stories tend to show a common theme
which is idea intensive industries
involving lots of entrepreneurship so
think back to nineteen seventy one in
Seattle where to real estate jokers put
up a sign with a last person to leave
Seattle please turn out the lights right
because Boeing was reducing its
employment and it seemed as if goodness
you know Seattle was an industrial town
how was it good ever come back you know
it's no better than Detroit and yet you
know this is before Microsoft before
Amazon before costco and starbucks was
just the faint whiff of a coffee aroma
and some blenders noses the the city
became right became a hub of
entrepreneurship but attracted through
skilled residents through skilled
entrepreneurs this remarkable chain of
employers and now is very much a model
of 21st century urban success obviously
I can tell similar stories about Boston
about the chain of invention come starts
out with MIT and then moves in first
into electronic technologies and then
moves into biotechnology smart people
working on each other's ideas creating
these chains of innovation New York of
course is primarily a story about
finance right forty-two percent of the
payroll in the island of Manhattan is in
finance and that's shouldn't surprise us
if the comparative advantage of cities
today is in enabling the flow of
information enabling the acquisition of
knowledge there's no industry where a
little bit of extra knowledge can
generate millions or perhaps even
billions of dollars more quickly than
finance which is why it's particularly
attracted to urban areas and while I
certainly hope and wish that New York
would have a more balanced industrial
structure as it did in one point in time
in the past New York is still much
better off with finance than it would be
without it because in fact that enables
the whole city to do the things that it
does now there's a sense in which
there's also a chain of invention in New
York and finance which tends at least
for me to illustrate this urban ability
to create chains as I think it did in
1880's architecture and Chicago or I'll
feel more comfortable talking about the
the chain of invention in Renaissance
Florence right where Brunelleschi
figures out the basic mathematics of
linear perspective passes it along to
his friend Donatello who puts
low relief sculpture on the outside wall
of awesome akeli below the statue of st.
George passes it along to his friend
masaccio who puts it on the wall of
brancaccio chapel that marvelous picture
of peter finding the coin in the belly
of the fish passes along to his friend
or student even fry filippo lippi that
less than st. a monk pass it along to
Botticelli and so for the chain of
invention well one smart person borrows
the others ideas and each new idea
creates more openings more avenues for
innovation they all knew each other they
all borrowed each other acts ideas and
they created this chain that changed the
world well this is the Economist me I
like to think a similar thing happened
in finance ok so infinite there's a
quantitative ability to think about the
trade-offs between risk and return which
starts off at the University of Chicago
with people like harry markowitz and
milton friedman and jimmy savage that
then gets carried by people like Fisher
black and Jack trainer to Wall Street
that ability to think quantitatively
about risk and return enables the young
Michael Milken then still living in New
York to convince investors that his
high-yield debt junk bonds if you will
carried enough return to offset the risk
those junk bonds that enabled the young
Henry Kravis to engage in larger and
larger leveraged buyouts I didn't push
American firms to become slightly more
attentive to shareholder interests the
rise of securitization Lou Ranieri who
got his skills in the Salomon Brothers
mailroom always a great place to acquire
skills in a city right as part of that
chain and so is this guy Michael
Bloomberg now in I was not in fact an
employee of Bloomberg View when I wrote
the book but now I am as you just heard
so that lets that sound is as disclosure
or as i like to call it advertising i'm
on every other tuesday the but i keep
Bloomberg in despite that for a reason
which is that he's both part of this
chain right his terminals are part of
this move towards a more quantitative
approach to finance it it delivers the
data that is the ultimate meat of that
and that's one reason why I keep it up
the second reason that I keep it up it
shows this ability that Jane Jacobs made
so much about of cities to permit
cross-industry fertilization she like to
talk about the invention of the bra New
York I like to talk about Bloomberg
terminals the the basic point of course
being that Bloomberg is not a financial
billionaire he's an information tech
billionaire right he jumps from Salomon
Brothers into information technology but
he's able to make that jump and be
successful in a way that no Silicon
Valley mobile living in splendid
isolation Atherton could ever been
because he's actually run the trading
floor at Salomon Brothers because he was
exiled to their tech operation he knows
what the guys at Merrill Lynch want and
he's able to deliver it right the city
has made him wise the city has made him
smart and he's able to make a leap
across industries and become wildly
successful as a result but I like this
for a third reason because it's actually
also about the physical space right this
is the bullpen at City Hall this Wallace
office where people connect with each
other right which is modeled on the
bullpen at Bloomberg LLP which is
modeled on the Salomon Brothers training
floor at least that's what Bloomberg
says the there's something while they're
certainly debates the City Hall about
how functional this is within city hall
there's no question that trading floors
are you know the universally ascribed to
two system within within financial
trading firms and in some sense there's
something odd about them because here we
have some of the wealthiest people in
the planet who in a normal industry
would sit protected by okin walls by
large offices right enjoying all the
purposes of privacy that their
prosperity should give them and yet here
they are right right on top of each
other right experiencing all the
discomfort of having someone else smell
your sweat right but they're there
because they need to know what's going
on they're there because they need to
hear to feel what's going on in the
markets to know what's happening there
they're ultimately they're willing to
put up with those inconveniences
ultimately because knowledge is more
important than space and that's
fundamentally why cities came back
because knowledge was more important
than space because people were willing
to put up with the inconveniences of
being close to each other in cities
because it was so important to be smart
right and this explains our puzzle that
we started with why globalization and
new technology that made cities more not
less important because what
globalization and new technologies have
done and there are literally hundreds of
studies showing this is that they have
increased the returns to being smart
they've increasing returns to innovation
they've increased returns to scale
they've increased returns to human
capital right because the world has
become more complicated because the
trivial tasks are automated because if
you have a new idea you can sell it on
the other side of the planet or you can
source it on the other side
the planet right all of these things
have made it much more valuable to be
inventive to be smart to have a new good
idea now that only plays into city
strengths because in fact we are social
species that get smart by being around
other smart people we are born we come
out of the womb with a remarkable
ability to soak up information from our
parents from our peers from our siblings
even occasionally from our teachers and
cities enable us to do that and it's
fine we can schedule and a
teleconference but you can't schedule
the unplanned things that Mike Bloomberg
would have gotten as a young man working
in Salomon Brothers you can't schedule
the things that you pick around right as
a young architect just being in Roberts
turns office right you can't you can't
schedule this stuff right you learn by
being there by seeing the people screw
up or or all of you by seeing them make
brilliant I decisions that's how we
learn that's certainly how I learned and
I suspect it's true of all of you and
cities make this happening they're not
at risk from the fact that we can you
know do some low-level interactions
electronically those things in fact make
the unplanned interactions even more
important and as the world gets more
complicated the value of face-to-face
connection also gets more valuable
anyone who teaches knows the hard part
about teaching is not knowing your
script it's knowing whether or not
anything you're saying is getting into
the heads of the people you're talking
to it's knowing whether or not anything
you're saying is catching their
imagination or or making their minds
click and we have evolved over millions
of years to have these remarkable cues
for communicating comprehension or
confusion at close quarters when you're
not in the same room you give that up
and it becomes far harder and the more
complicated the ideas the more you're
likely to lose by not being there now
all of these stories of course have
statistics that go along with them what
you're looking at here is the
relationship between the share of the
population with the college degree as of
1970 and subsequent population growth
across all the metropolitan areas in the
u.s. it's a nice positive relationship
but if you look just at the older cities
of the Northeast in the Midwest it's a
remarkably strong relationship skills
really our destiny for this group you
want to understand why Boston is doing
better than buffalo in New York is doing
better than Detroit right you just look
at the share the population with college
degrees about one in eight adults in
Detroit have a college degree more than
fifty percent of adults in Seattle do
right
that these cities are doing exactly as
well as you'd expect a human capital to
cause them to do the most educated group
here as of with as of 1970 experienced
subsequent growth rates of fifty three
percent the least educated experienced
growth rates of of eight percent right
enormous gulf human capital is the
bedrock on which cities and nations last
this is of course came out after the
book this is population growth 2002 2010
and education across all the counties in
the US and as you can see the most
educated fifth had growth about 13% the
least educated fifth head growth of
about three percent enormous connection
between skills and success right I often
argue the best economic development
strategy is to attract and empowered
smart people and then more or less get
out of their way and that's certainly
what we saw over and over again in
cities that people like that the Bill
Gates or the oh no I'm going to levis
boarded Gates Foundation I need to
disclose that as well the starbucks guys
i do occasionally drink starbucks coffee
well the okay the the skills really
aren't ask me and one way to think about
this is what economists call human
capital externalities and what you're
looking at here is what would they be
enormously eloquent title the log wage
residual like that which is essentially
your wages controlling for everything i
know about you and then we take this we
average this so controlling for your
years of school and then we connect this
with the share of the population in your
metropolitan area with a college degree
and the fact is that as the share of the
population within your metropolitan area
the college degree increases by ten
percent your wages go up on average by
eight percent holding your skills
constant the work of Enrico Moretti has
really shown this and there are a whole
bunch of sort of smart statistical ways
of getting at this like those cities
that had land-grant colleges prior to
nineteen forty those metropolitan areas
have done remarkably better over the
last twenty years there really is some
truth to daniel patrick moynihan zone
old line that the best way to build a
successful city was to attract two
world-class universities in wait 50
years the this of course has a
long-standing history of series i'm just
going to skip over this but the most
important skills in cities of course are
not the things that people learn in
college in fact i'm often amazed that
anyone finds any practically used to
anything I say it's the things that are
learned outside of colleges the things
that lure anniera learned in the Salomon
Brothers mailroom
and in fact it's hard to think of
anything that's more important for urban
success than skills and inclination to
be an entrepreneur a fifty years ago the
Economist bench units argued that New
York appeared to be more resilient than
Pittsburgh even then because New York's
industrial history one was one that was
extremely conducive towards the
accumulation of entrepreneurial human
capital that the garment industry New
York's dominant industry was an industry
in which anyone could get started with a
couple of sewing machines and good idea
all right and in fact in my book I tell
the story of 80 left Court who built
more skyscrapers than a new york who did
prior to the 1929 which he when he
famously declared that he was sure that
1930 would be the greatest of all
building years and I'm paraphrasing he
was wrong on that showing a showing it
perhaps an irrational exuberance that
occasionally does show up in the
development community the end of course
that the father standing while a city
court also starts in the garment
industry it's its Legion the number of
people get their start in this where
it's very easy to begin your own firm by
contrast think about Pittsburgh and US
Steel right how the heck you know
Pittsburgh US Steel trains company men
right it didn't train entrepreneurs you
you work for pits prefer us deal for
your life you weren't going to start
some new company if you a steel went
down no more than the guys who worked
for General Motors we're going to go out
on their own and start some new company
with General Motors faltered so that can
be again enormously productive in the
short run but when it comes to
reinventing the city I'll take
entrepreneurship any day of the week and
measures of entrepreneurship like the
share of employment in start-up so this
is another popular measure which is the
average firm size the number of firms
per worker places with lots of lots of
little firms are over they are in places
with a few big firms and what you can
see is the places that have lots of
little firm said about three times more
employment growth between 1977 and 2000
the place with the places with a few
large firms and we can actually trace
things back my work with bilker we've
actually gone back and looked at mineral
ore deposits in 1900 which then predicts
having large firms and then seeing that
that that bears out on the whole
economic history of the city over the
next hundred years that their large firm
70 years later even in financial
services even industries unrelated to
these orders and the places do more
poorly over the last two decades now the
success of cities right is of course
accompanied as I suggested at the being
of the paper by enormous challenge
as well right if two people are close
enough to give an idea give each other
an idea face to face they're also close
enough to give each other contagious
disease and if you're close enough to
sell somebody a newspaper you're also
close enough to rob that person and for
3,000 years cities have been battling
with the downsides of density perhaps
the most important downside of density
is contagious almost surely waterborne
diseases right which turned our cities
into killing fields throughout most of
their history aboard born in New York
City in 1900 could expect to live seven
years less than the national average
current life expectancy is about two
years longer in New York than the
national average no one exactly knows
why that's true among older New Yorkers
why there currently is more health some
people argue that it's walking some
people argue that social connection
among young people it's really obvious
though it's lower levels of suicide rate
in large cities and lower levels of
motor vehicle accidents just taking the
subways after a few drinks it's just a
heck of lot safer and getting behind the
wheel of a car but the safety of cities
didn't happen cheaply right the battle
for clean water was extraordinarily
difficult and extraordinarily expensive
and it involved a number of mistaken
turns in the 1790s most of the major
cities along the eastern seaboard
battled with yellow fever epidemic and
while they certainly didn't understand
the basic medicine of it they certainly
thought that providing better water
would be one step forward Philadelphia
went the way of providing public water
works which latrobe did New York
followed is somewhat crazy
public-private partnership cooked up by
by these two characters really burrs
idea right that he was going to get the
ability to run a bank by promising to
provide water so burr hires Hamilton
whom of course he would later shoot to
be his lawyer representing his interest
of the Federalist City Council and
Hamilton explained to his Federalist but
he's using language that would be so
recognizable today that public provision
of water would lead to burthen some
taxes that New York could not possibly
pay so as a result the federal City
Council went along with burrs idea and
gave him the right to run a water
company that was going to be subsidized
with the ability of bird to run a bank
right now any economist should worth his
salt should know that this is a stupid
design of a system right you don't
incentivize a relatively non immunity of
activity providing clean water by giving
some the ability to a highly
remunerative activity instead right and
unsurprisingly of course burrs company
did
lot of banking and not a lot of water
provision of course it's now JP Morgan
Chase which was the Chase Manhattan Bank
which was the back of the Manhattan
water company it's still with us and it
still isn't producing a lot of water
although it is in fact it appears to be
an urban myth that this thing is
actually the cross section of a water
pipe although I again that's an urban
myth that I like but it doesn't actually
appear to be true now some things like
water required massive public
interventions massive massive public
investments but other urban curses like
congestion right can't be solved by
engineering the loan we can't just build
our way out of traffic jams there's
something called the fundamental law of
traffic congestion which shows this is
the work of shield Durham Matthew Turner
that vehicle miles traveled increase
roughly one for one with highway miles
built if you build it they will drive
and the only way to get people to you
know to not to you city streets is
charge them for it to actually price
valuable commodities like we price
everything else and Singapore which is
the second densest country on the planet
has relatively rapidly moving streets as
you can tell because they charge people
for driving on crowded city streets you
can't run you know the old Soviet style
grocery system didn't work very well
right you give away a valuable commodity
and you charge far too little of it no
results as long lines and stock outs
well that's what we're doing with our
urban traffic policy right we're running
a soviet-style traffic policy where we
give away something valuable for low
prices and the result is long lines and
stock outs right which exactly what an
urban traffic jam it is and you know the
right to drive freely on dros was not
snuck into the Bill of Rights somewhere
after the Fourth Amendment right I mean
there's no reason why you can't price
these things and indeed Singapore works
well now if cities are able to deal with
the downsides of density they can be
places of enormous pleasure as well as
productivity the same innovation and
entrepreneurship that makes it eases to
do cutting-edge technologies also makes
them great places to eat cutting-edge
cuisines right and the same ability of
cities to pay for the fixed costs of
having a sugar refinery in the early
19th century also enables them to pay
for the fixed cost of having a big great
Museum or having a great opera house
right that scale helps make cities fun
but of course the most fun thing about
cities is the fact that other people are
there right one of the things of course
that's striking is how much you know how
many young single people are attracted
to living in urban areas well they're
above all because that's where other
young single people are and that's
again you know cities as as marriage
Marcus if you prefer or the now that
this of course required this sort of
relatively rosy vision of cities of
course required also dealing with these
demons and I haven't had time to talk
about the crime problem but this again
required you know a very significant
public investment and one that in fact
you know while the streets have become
dramatically safer showing a huge public
success it has only been done at the
cost of incarcerating vast numbers of
Americans and and we haven't actually
figured out how to do this in a way that
is is that a lower human cost now the
consequence of having City succeed as
place as a pleasure and as well as
productivity is the demand for urban
space goes up right now I'm going to be
a real economist for you demand for
urban space goes up and if that demand
is not met with no more supply then
prices will rise there's no repealing
the laws of supply and demand and that's
exactly what has happened in many of our
olders colder cities the ones that
actually did manage to come back so what
you're looking at here is the declining
number of permits in New York that's the
following one and the rising number of
prices just as New York was getting its
act together it was actually building
fewer and fewer units and if you want to
understand why New York's growth was
below expectations of the last decade
you only need to look at the permitting
activity because typically population
growth is just a few percentage points
below the number of permits and given
the permitting activity in New York
between 2000-2010 it's exactly the
population growth that you would expect
Boston had faster population growth in
the state of Massachusetts for the first
time since eighteen seventy precisely
because the Boston Redevelopment
Authority assiduously went after
permitting more more units and when
cities say no to building whether it's
because of traditional zoning rules or
modern preservation districts they're
ensuring that the city isn't going to
grow as much and they're ensuring that
prices are going to go up doesn't mean
that those policies are wrong it just
means that there's always a cost to them
right and this is I think where you know
Jane Jacobs made what I think is their
most important mistake and it's not that
she was for something that was wrong I
mean there are certainly very good
arguments for things like the Greenwich
village preservation district but
Historic Preservation district but she
also made the argument which turns out
to be completely wrong that preserving
old buildings was going to preserve
affordability in the city and she used
her ground I level of journalistic
observation to note that old buildings
were cheap and new buildings were
expensive and that led her to conclude
that the way to make sure that cities
remain cheap was to make sure that no
one built any new buildings on top of
old buildings well that is not how
supply and demand works right you do not
preserve affordability by not letting
anyone deliver more space to the area by
freezing an area in in amber and you
need look no further than Greenwich
Village which is extraordinarily
charming place and I am in no sense
right denigrating the charms of
Greenwich Village but I will say one
thing it is not affordable okay it is
not a cheap place where you can buy a
townhouse the way that Jane Jacobs and
her husband did do 260 years ago if
you're an ordinary income American now
this is you know this is the cost of
restricting building it doesn't mean
that it's wrong but it always means that
any time you're saying no to a new unit
that's being built you're saying no to a
family that would like to move into the
city and you're saying saying that the
families that do live there are going to
face higher prices she was by the way
completely right about the high rise
high res public housing districts which
is a slightly different slightly
different issue but America has
undergone a sea change in the way that
we approach housing limitations and what
you're looking at here and we're huge
differences across space a way the way
Americans being shaped is being shaped
by local land use decisions if you want
to understand why Dallas and Houston and
Phoenix and Atlanta all added a million
people or more between 2000-2010 those
are the metropolitan areas you need look
no further than the fact that they make
it extraordinarily easy to build these
are not the most of these places don't
have the most productive productive
economies they don't have the most
charming climates and yet they make it
easy to build and so they do build what
you notice here is the places that are
really expensive don't build a lot and
places that build a lot aren't really
expensive that can't be explained by
just saying that there are you know
their differences in demand there's
plenty of demand for New York and
there's plenty of demand for Las Vegas
or at least they used to be but most
agus because it allows building adds a
lot of people New York because it allows
less building as it becomes more
expensive I've occasionally been seen as
being a supporter of skyscrapers is if I
had an opinion on
where people should live I don't I
believe that people should have choices
and I personally think skyscrapers are
nice but I / certainly understand people
who don't like it what I've tried to
emphasize is their cost to restricting
that type of development and in fact we
need to take into account those costs
when we when we make these decisions and
while the consequences of excessive
restrictions on building in the u.s. in
the US are significant they're
extraordinary and I would argue even
catastrophic in cities like Mumbai which
is labeled under a maximum floor area
ratio in much of the city of one and a
quarter over much of the last 40 years
motivated by a I would argue benign tdu
that restricting floor area ratios will
artificially you know limit the growth
of the city of course it hasn't limited
the growth of the city I don't think
they should have been trying to limit
the growth of the city and all it has
done is ensured that the city is
dysfunctional that it built out instead
of up that it developed none of the sort
of highly connected taller areas that
would have led towards usable sidewalks
and the tragedy is that India remains
far poorer than it would have been if
Mumbai and the other cities of India
have been able to play their role more
more surely of moving the country
towards towards development I want to
end with a with an environmental story
because I think one of the reasons why
allowing cities to build up while
allowing urban growth is so valuable is
the cities also have an environmental
role to play the ancient view of cities
which is that they're sort of you know
there's the it's the sort of lorax
fallacy if you will that that you know
living around nature is green and living
around cities is brown I think that's
fundamentally mistaken and I like to
tell a story of a young Harvard graduate
who a beautiful spring day in 1844 went
for a walk in the woods outside of
Concord and he went to do a little
fishing with a friend of his and the
fishing was good because they hadn't
been much rain lately and when he came
to cook the fish into a chowder that's
what we do up in New England we cooked
chowder's the wind flicked the flames to
the nearby dry grass and a flame and a
fire started and it spread and it became
an inferno and by the time it was done
it wiped out more than 300 acres of
prime woodland almost an entire you know
small ecosystem you know eradicated from
the face of the earth in his own day
this young man was castigated as an
enemy the environment the Concord
Freeman called him a flibbertigibbet
which I think was pretty bad for 1844
and indeed
um you know they were surely right to do
so I can't think of any young man living
in boston or cambridge in 1844 who did
as much damage the environment as this
guy of course somewhat oddly his today
revered is the secular saint of american
environmentalism he's henry david
thoreau whose book Walden appears to
preach a gospel of what a wonderful that
thing it is for people to live around
nature where's his own life seems to
tell a slightly different story right i
mean i think the moral of the thorough
story is that we are very destructive
species and if you live nature it's
often best if you love nature is often
best to stay away from it as indeed
Thoreau would have done nature a
tremendous turn if he had stayed in
cambridge and stuck to his books instead
of going out into the woods now i know
of what I speak because as I mentioned
at the beginning I to left the city as
such as it is of Cambridge five years
ago when I started acquiring small
children only economist talk about
acquiring small children and move to
move to a suburb not that far away from
Walden Pond this is a story that
similarly accounted by david owen is in
his fine book green metropolis and of
course i found myself doing what
americans do everywhere and you know
meeting a whole lot of using a whole lot
more energy than i ever had living in an
urban area both from of course driving
and from the fact that the house size
increase and so you lose a lot more
energy together with matthew khan i
tried to estimate carbon emissions
associated with a standardized household
meaning you don't want to just compare
city residents and suburban ice and
assume that they are identical right
because the Bourbon heights are more
likely to be somewhat wealthier the more
likely have a larger family you want to
control for those things but even
controlling for those things is a fairly
significant gap between suburban energy
use in central city energy use and it's
coming both from smaller housing units
and cities it's not again that
apartments use less energy per square
foot then then suburban homes they don't
they actually use more but it's when
people are living in apartments they're
just living in such smaller units per
capita that they end up using
significantly less energy and then of
course it's also less from less energy
from the combination of driving and
public transit and foremost of americans
before you get too hung up on public
transit this is mostly about driving
shorter distances rather than longer
distances because our country is still
very much oriented towards the
automobile and but there are huge gains
even from living in more compact spaces
in terms of energy use even if you're
not getting into a getting into a car
i'm going to skip over that i'm going to
skip over that
just end on this note which is that the
the if Indian China like the great
growing economies of Indian China see
their carbon emissions rise to the level
seen in the sprawling United States
global carbon emissions will go up by
about one hundred and thirty percent
just on its own nothing else changing no
population increasing massive increase
if they rise but stop at the level seen
at hyper dense but still prosperous Hong
Kong global carbon emissions go up by
less than thirty percent right I don't
care if you're interested in global
warming you just care about the price of
gas at the pump right it's the whole
world is a lot to be gained if you
needing to build up rather than
sprawling out in terms of their
emissions and that's one reason why we
need to I think is a country we think
our own policies that artificially push
people away from urban centers and
that's the combination of the home
mortgage interest deduction as I
mentioned this combination of
subsidizing car usage on highways and
it's also about our very difficult
system of local local schools there's
nothing more that pushes parents away
from cities in the way that we've
structure our schools and that doesn't
have to be there are cities from Paris
to Stockholm that do a wonderful job of
giving parents great schools that they
locate in the city we just need to be
more creative and allow the same powers
of urban innovation entrepreneurship to
do great things for restaurants to do
great things for for food as well cities
continue to face challenges and the
world continues to face challenges but I
don't want an eye these challenges are
enormous be they global warming be the
problems of poverty but I think the
basic message that I want to end on is
hopeful because we have been facing
challenges as species for thousands and
thousands of years and our ability as a
species to work miracles to solve on be
a the provision of clean water or the
creation of the the skyscraper or
Renaissance art our ability to work
miracles is remarkable and we don't do
it as solo operators we do it when we're
connected when we leverage each other
when we learn from each other and that's
what makes universities work and schools
work and it's also what makes cities
were this would make them such a special
part of humanity thank you very much
for us to admit that someone at Harvard
could give a good talk but thank you
very very much for the body I'm sure
there are some questions and comments
for people in the audience started with
Alex garbage but wait for the mic table
that you showed at the beginning the 10
largest cities in the United States at
one winner Los Angeles with it increase
of eighty-seven percent how do you
explain that success well it seems to it
seems to verify the sunshine hypothesis
doesn't it right I mean it's a
combination of Sun and Sun and sprawl
but there are of course other things
involved in in Los Angeles it also has a
cluster of talent right it also the the
role of entertainment in Los Angeles I
think continues to illustrate the role
the cities have in creating creativity
one of the things that I was struck by
when I was doing research for this book
which you know nothing's better than
doing research for books about cities
because if he's walking around cities
which is you know pretty much the best
thing in the world but I was struck
walking around the slums of Mumbai or
call kinda how darn ubiquitous the ads
for James Cameron's movie Avatar work
right that that you couldn't escape the
avatar signs and it just seemed to be a
symbol of here was this thing created by
American ingenuity being sold everywhere
and it sort of reminded you about what
you know the magic that comes out of
urban connection even on the other on
the other coast Los Angeles is not on
off the regression line it really is
exactly you know and it's it's exactly
where you'd expect it to be given the
combination of sunshine and and you know
it also takes advantage of the car of
the car orientation as well but it's not
it's not doing surprisingly it's not
doing surprisingly well relative to
those sort of fundamentals if you will
to company town ok well there's also
airs be here in the end table business
or you're not via yes question back
there so it sounds like the unplanned
exchange of ideas is one of the most
important aspects of a city's value but
it also sounds like that's something
that's very hard to measure and when if
there's some kind of data
when you can look at to try to quantify
that directly well people try to the I
mean one of the things that we use to
measure the exchange of ideas is the
things like citation rates to patents so
the work of a it's too late and evening
work on patent citation is showing a
very strong tendency of people to cite
patents that are close they're
physically proximate to them which I
think shows some evidence of that
although that isn't exactly unplanned
stuff there also is significant evidence
of actually experimental work where they
allow people to meet face-to-face versus
not and shows significant better
coordination as a result of those
face-to-face meetings but you're right
the unplanned stuff is incredibly hard
to measure one thing that I'm hoping to
convince the Boston Redevelopment
Authority to allow me to do is they are
curating a building this innovation
district downtown and on the waterfront
and they are allowing a certain number
of people to enter it below market rate
housing for sort of entrepreneurial
spaces and they're going to curate in
who the entrepreneurs in our and I am
being a something of a social scientist
I'm trying to convince them to actually
once they select their you know 100
entrepreneurs text you randomize in 50
of them so we all have ingenuine
treatment and control of what the what
the impact is on long-run
entrepreneurial success of being
randomized into the to this physical
space versus not being randomized in but
you're right measurement does tend to be
difficult the more unplanned and it's
also is the less about why I mean the
work of josh lerner called boulevard and
broken dreams reminds us about how the
unplanned nature of urban innovation
entrepreneurship uses most public
attempts to micromanage it from City
Hall have been colossal failures that it
is very very difficult to sort of play
venture capitalists from from a local
government and the most successful
examples we've seen Industrial Policy
are at least I would argue human capital
policy in disguise so Singapore is
typically held up as being a relatively
successful move along I think the most
positive view of what Lee Kuan Yew did
was by pushing Singapore gradually up
the food chain of industries he actually
up skilled as people and enable them to
move up to the next the next level I
think that's just as a general lesson
about how you think about economic
development investments I think the
right thing to ask is not how many jobs
it's creating today but how many skills
and how many entrepreneurs is creating
five years from now that's that's the
question that you have to ask you
about these about these investments
question way back there we'll bring you
the mic I don't know enough time has
elapsed for us to see the changes that
can be brought by the internet and how
people interact because of Internet you
know I can imagine rooms filled with
cameras all over and screens all over
that allow for that unplanned
interaction that you're talking about
it's possible hey you know it's I've
been grappling with this issue for
almost 20 years I wrote my first paper
on our electronic communications and
face-to-face communications compliments
or substitutes which is the Economist
way of saying it 1994 and there we were
more worried about faxes then we were
about about the internet but it is
remarkable I mean one of the one of the
data points that are there a number of
data points that you look for us for
example who are the big users of these
technologies are the people who are in
dense urban areas versus not and
typically people who connect
electronically are also people meet each
other right people who you don't call
people very often who you're not likely
to me unless you're in the solicitation
business but another piece of evidence
is what happened to the time series of
business travel right so all this
electronic communication was supposed to
make business travel unnecessary because
after all we just you know connect but
the opposite happened right starting in
1985 there was an explosion in the
amount of business travel which didn't
seem to be explained by anything going
on in terms of changing fares also
there's things like the rise and
co-authorship and various disciplines or
my own favorite data point which is of
course we the whole history of the
telephone which 110 years ago was
thought to be a great boon for rural
living but it was going to level the
playing field between cities and rural
life and end this crazy organization
trend that didn't that clearly didn't
happen I'd in fact most of the time we
think of telephones is being positively
associated with urbanization not not
negatively associated but my favorite
data point on us is in fact that the
industry of all industries that you
think of as having the best access to
electronic communications is also the
industry that has become the most famous
example of a geographic cluster in the
world today Silicon Valley right if
there's one industry where you think
they would have solved this problem and
would have no need to be face to face it
would be them if they're one company
that would be able to do this it would
be Google right
but what does Google do they build the
Googleplex right they build a sitting so
that everyone can be right next to each
other and can learn from one other what
is a pose do it tries to we redevelop
Las Vegas I mean it's the the the guys
in this industry understand that you
actually have to be in the midst of
things in order to learn in any any time
I talked to a young software young
ambitious software person they will
uniformly tell tell me that they need to
actually go to Silicon Valley to be in
the mix right they need to be there
physically around the people where the
action is in order to acquire the skills
to be successful in their in their
energy shore we can manage to you know
do consulting in bangalore but you know
to be to be there as value of course
banglar itself is now an example of you
know extreme connectivity of the people
who are living there maybe from the US
perspective it's a flat world phenomenon
worse than the edge of nowhere but from
the Indian perspective right it's a
teeming hive of entrepreneurial and
innovative talent but you're right we
don't know and you know once we have the
beam me up scotty technology all bets
are off the keller just wondering in all
the places where you've been giving
talks maybe many of them in the united
states which is a suburban nation do you
find that your audiences are surprised
and flabbergasted by this information
and you know in some ways are you have
you written a book that is I mean for
many Urbanists right this is this is
this is sort of Mother's Milk this
message right but but so so are you in a
sense writing a book that's kind of
slide 11 to a suburban nation I
certainly I certainly hope to write I
mean one of the reasons why I wrote this
book was to try and challenge the notion
that you know it's the the suburban home
is the only way to rear of American
unquestionably I believe that very
strongly and that's certainly one of the
reasons I wrote it on the other hand it
runs it up against my basic you that
it's almost impossible to change grown
adults minds on anything as to mention i
do you not to mention students they're
nice no I think if they're if they
haven't thought enough about the issue
you have
some chance so i think that's that's the
that's that's the hope i think probably
actually we're I've had the but American
battle lines are so drawn on this stuff
and the politics are just awful right I
mean being connected with one political
party is a terrible place to be in terms
of in terms of the political debate you
really want to be desperately fought
over by the two parties you want to be
in the center and you know cities have
this long-standing PR problem that
everyone can see what the heck a cow
does what a farmer does we can all get
misty-eyed about the silos and the week
that feeds us and nobody knows exactly
what an urban you know design consultant
does or even worse than urban management
consultant or financier worst of all
right I mean it so the Joel's just seems
mysterious and and and and wicked and
and I think all of these things make it
very very hard to push to push back in
this on top of the fact that we've
rigged the Senate in a way that over you
know overpowers give to use too much to
give us excessive power to low density
areas relative to high density areas the
area where I think I actually have that
have felt as if I've had some success in
terms of changing minds is actually most
in the developing world where you
actually have that you don't have the
battle line strong where they're not
sure exactly what they think about
cities versus rural areas where there's
some of the Gandhi asked stuff that's
still around but they're certainly
they're well aware that they're living
in a world in which the cities are
making them cities are changing the
countries and they are actually as a
world in which there's much more
openness on this but certainly I hope to
have an impact closer to home but I'm
less and less optimistic but I that it
was I have but have time for one more
question yes well as an architect I
found the title of your book very
encouraging but could you talk a little
bit more about your choice of title and
particular perhaps about the order in
which you put the adjectives the I
received in advance from the publisher
for a book that was not titled the same
as this book and the publisher made up
the title and there was a certain amount
of fighting about I tried to actually
keep happier out of the title but I was
unsuccessful on successful on that and I
bout the publishers superior knowledge
on this but I had
I had absolutely no input whatsoever on
the actual choice of words I the title
even authors it would appear have
clients they indeed you know you can see
my own my own tremendous skill at coming
up with catchy titles and the titles say
my previous book cities agglomeration
economies and I can't even remember I'm
I send us and the spatial equilibrium
guaranteed to sell guaranteed to sell
three three copies so given how given
how adept I thought I given that i knew
my own limitations in this area it
seemed it seemed best to just cave in
but i had no i had no input to do with
it okay is it a message is there and
last question and certainly a
fascinating what went back there I don't
want to cut anything off anyone off have
you looked into what roles artists play
in revitalizing cities is that you talk
about at all it's very very hard to
quantify this and I certainly believe it
extraordinarily but I mean I certainly
believe that beauty's is an incredibly
valuable urban asset and it's certainly
something that we cherish it turns out
to be very hard to actually do this in a
serious quantitative way you know the
the correlations that I talked about
like the skills urban success
correlation are incredibly profound and
you know I certainly believe that one
potential reason for this is one of the
things that skilled people do is they
move to cities that are more beautiful
and then that's part of what makes them
successful sorry I've just I mean it's
really a practicing artist I mean as
artists as say save Venice Beach you
know de left rundown place where artists
move first and then yeah sort of me
people followed and then look at you can
there's there's lots of you can read my
review of richard florida's book written
12 years about this and i'm very
friendly with richard in fact if you if
you look at the book i mean he cites my
i mean someone remembers being in a car
supposedly where I told him that there
was a correlation between skills and
urban growth but when you try and look
at least when I try to look at other
measures of creativity I found nothing
that was statistically significant once
you'd control for the share of the
population with a college degree in the
initial beard which doesn't mean that it
isn't so right i mean it's this is a
very important thing about the
limitations of statistics
means that you can't actually say it one
way or the other with any degree of
precision so it's not that I you know
it's not that I don't believe in my
bones that actually having a thriving
creative community in the in the area
and lots of ways is incredibly value i
do believe that but I couldn't you know
I don't think the data gives you the
you're best off just believing in your
in your you know in the life that you
live rather than trust me about say
Detroit so why why aren't you know
people educated people moving there you
know why people moving because they want
that sort of energy which sometimes is
created oh the mic up or no amor you
what you're saying I don't know if this
is work art is working i could do it um
I just that's kind of weird I guess for
Detroit how do you see Detroit sort of I
mean it's kind of a big question oh the
Detroit question how do you see Detroit
coming back I mean the Detroit has
unbelievably cheap housing there's this
wonderful legacy has lots of beautiful
buildings or at least I think they're
beautiful again I have no standing on
that but it's got an enormously high
hurdle to fly it up right I mean if you
think that successful cities are about
small firm smart people in connection to
the outside world Detroit had you know
was the epitome of big firms an
industrial monoculture right and you
know lower levels of a formal education
this is an enormously difficult hurdle
to go over and the politics of Detroit
didn't help it I think right now Detroit
has sort of basic physical problems it
needs to think about shrinking its
physical footprint in a way that's smart
needs to be about providing
infrastructure that's appropriate for a
radically smaller city than the one that
it was built for it needs to figure out
what to do wisely with its space um but
I think the right question going forward
is not to ask yourself how Detroit can
come back in the sense of being a city
of you know 1.2 1.85 million people
again it's actually how to ask whether
not the children living in Detroit will
have a brighter future whether or not
they stay in that city or not which is
more of an issue of asking about how to
make sure that their streets are safe
and their schools are competent I mean
just once I want to hear mayor say sure
my city lost ten percent of its
population row and watch but the people
who left went on to great jobs in dallas
in Seattle and I'm proud of that because
I educated them to do that and you know
that really is you know that the
ultimate mission of city governments is
too
you know in Richmond power the lives
their citizens whether they stay there
or not I think that's Detroit really has
to be focused on the people and that's I
guess if I had a final messin message to
a room full of architects you know who
do this thing that I revere and that I
cherish every day of my life seeing the
work of architects of this this age and
past once it's that there's this
wonderful synergy between the human
capital in the physical capital and that
while I do argue that the real city is
the human capital that human capital
realized critically on the physical
capital that surrounds it on the beauty
on the ideas on the structures that are
built and it's ultimately all about the
magic of that synergy in terms of the
success of success of cities I'll and
thank you